[Musique]
ne cherchez pas ton idée serait à
l'entraînement au stade de Vierzon cette
semaine il est dans la paix nombre de sa
chambre à l'entraînement virtuel joue
tout le temps en cas de 3 donc ça se
composition là pour garder le score je
vais jouer en 5-40 à 5 défenseurs parce
que là-bas il y aura des gros joueurs
avec plus d'expérience que moi je pense
ton
[Musique]
y un jour gagné la finale départementale
puis régionale sur Fifa c'est fait c'est
la meilleure équipe on va dire
non merci au début comme tous les
parents sa mère se plaignait de le voir
passer des journées entières sur la
console comment tu te sens pour la
compétition
aujourd'hui elle lui apporte des
plateaux repas dans sa chambre tu vas
nous emmener le titre j'espère il faut
savoir se sacrifier et oui avec le
sourire maintenant avec le sourire mais
pas au début au début j'étais un peu
énervé mais bon maintenant voilà il a
prouvé de ce qu'il est capable de faire
et c'est son objectif il lâchera rien
donc ça c'est une passion que j'ai
depuis tout petit que mon frère m'a
transmis j'irai une mélo il joue
actuellement à Tenerife en ligue
d'espagnol si je peux faire comme lui je
le ferai avec son c'est un peu mon rêve
mais si je peux pas je le ferai qu'une
manette c'est pas grave au club
Noël qui ne s'est toujours pas remis
d’être passé aussi près de la Coupe de
France de football se réjouit de voir
Tony son service civique en finale on
l'a recrutait au club parce qu'on savait
qu'il avait des qualités en Playstation
4 donc là il l'a prouvé en étant
champion régional et il est très motivé
pour se classer au mieux dans cette
compétition nationale à Clairefontaine
ce week-end le FC Vierzon suivra son
champion sur Internet lundi c'est le
tournoi annuel en vrai sur la pelouse et
peut-être un titre national virtuel
c'est toujours ça